bonjour Est-ce que vous m'entendez bien
je vous invite à me répondre sur le chat
bonjour bonjour Est-ce que vous
m'entendez bien est-ce que nous sommes
bien connectés à vous
OK
bonjour je vois que
ok est-ce que tout le monde est connecté
OK
donc si vous m'entendez bien bonjour et
a priori Emma serait compétences tout le
monde est là et ça ne mobilité OK
très bien alors bonjour je suis Sandrine
Charles je suis
communicante à la chambre de métier
d'artisanat de l'Essonne je vais animer
cette conférence aujourd'hui je vous
remercie de participer à cette cinquième
édition de ma journée découverte de
l'apprentissage qui est organisé par la
Chambre de métier de l'artisanat de
l'Essonne en partenariat avec la Faculté
des Métiers de l'Essonne le CFA du
bâtiment de Brétigny et les Apprentis
d'Auteuil de Marcoussis les cinq web
conférences que nous vous proposons
aujourd'hui dans le cadre de la Semaine
nationale de l'apprentissage sont
consacrés à votre orientation vers les
métiers de l'automobile du goût de la
beauté de la fleuristerie et du bâtiment
métier qui font partie de la grande
famille de l'artisanat
avant de commencer cette web conférence
je j'aimerais vous faire part de
quelques éléments de contexte ça va pas
prendre mon temps mais ça permet de
resituer un petit peu l'artisanat et
l'apprentissage dans le cadre économique
de la France
l'artisanat français est un secteur qui
a le vent en poupe
un million 830 000 entreprises
artisanales ont été recensées en juin
2022 soit plus de 80 000 en un an donc
c'est justifié l'artisanat plait aux
jeunes
c'est évident aujourd'hui un créateur
d'entreprise sur quatre crée une
entreprise artisanale ce qui atteste par
ailleurs du dynamisme de ce secteur
quête de sens valorisation du fabriqué
en France recherche d'épanouissement
professionnel et personnel toutes ces
valeurs poussent aussi bien les jeunes
que les adultes en reconversion
professionnelle vers l'artisanat un
véritable
porteur porteur d'un nouveau modèle
économique en fait on voit bien que
aujourd'hui on a envie de travailler un
peu autrement
la preuve
178.000 apprentis ont été formés dans
l'artisanat en 2020 en 2021 c'est
l'année scolaire 2020 2021 c'est plus
15% par rapport à l'année précédente
donc c'est un record qui a été inégalé
qui prouve bien que l'apprentissage fait
partie intégrante de l'ADN de
l'artisanat
sachez que la formation par la voie de
l'apprentissage
offre de très belles perspectives
professionnelles
80% des apprentis trouve un job dans les
6 à 8 mois qui à la fin de leurs études
voilà de quoi alimenter vos discussions
et surtout nous espérons que cet
événement suscitera d'évocations c'est
l'objet un peu de ces conférences place
maintenant à la présentation de la
filière des métiers de l'automobile
autour de la table j'accueille
myriama faut pas que je me trompe dans
le photographe meryama caldi vous êtes
chargé du développement de la filière
automobile à la Faculté des Métiers de
l'Essonne
au bout de cette table j'accueille
Théodore
sobolaise vous êtes apprenti dans quelle
classe
j'accueille aussi que je me trompe pas
Nathan non c'est pas Nathan c'est Loane
Loane Colin tu es apprenti en quelle
classe
[Musique]
et Nathan je vais pas utiliser vos noms
on va s'appeler par nos prénoms
Nathan tu es également apprenti à la
faculté des métiers en automobile dans
quelle classe la même que la leur je
suis en bac pro carrosserie voilà et
bien écoutez cette conférence va
commencer je vous invite à poser toutes
vos questions sur le chat qui est
disponible
voilà derrière votre écran et nous y
répondrons globalement à la fin de ce
webinaire qui va pas durer cette
présentation va durer une vingtaine de
minutes entre 20 et 30 minutes je laisse
la parole à Amira au pardon et voilà je
l'ai faite
myriama qui va nous présenter vous
présenter la filière de l'automobile à
Faculté des Métiers je vous souhaite une
très belle conférence et je vous donne
rendez-vous tout à l'heure je poserai
des questions aux apprentis au cours de
cette présentation mais surtout nous
répondrons à toutes vos questions après
à tout à l'heure
donc du coup comme m'a très bien
présenté Sandrine moi je suis chargée
développement commercial sur la filière
automobile donc l'objectif c'est
vraiment qu'on puisse sans trop entrer
dans les détails mais vous présenter un
petit peu ce qui représentait la faculté
des métiers au sein de cette filière là
donc effectivement on va parler du
contrat d'apprentissage on va parler des
métiers de la débouchés de ces contrats
là dans la filière automobile on va
également donc voir ensemble au niveau
de la Faculté des Métiers comment sont
partagés les différents secteurs que ce
soit secteur carrosserie peinture ou
secteur donc mécanique maintenance des
véhicules et effectivement donc à la fin
comme vous la dit Sandrine on va avoir
la question-Réponses qui seront
récoltées au fur et à mesure au niveau
du chat
donc là voilà vous retrouvez un petit
peu plus les intitulés de chaque
personne qui a été présentée au début
donc je remercie d'ailleurs les trois
apprentis qui ont accepté de
m'accompagner pour donc déjà faire part
de leur expérience et par la suite il
vous parleront un petit peu plus donc de
leur de leur cursus
et donc voilà donc l'apprentissage
qu'est-ce que c'est l'apprentissage il
faut savoir que nous au sein de la
Faculté des Métiers on a déjà plus de 90
formations qui concerne l'apprentissage
à tout type de niveau donc ça veut dire
que dès vous sortez de votre troisième
ayant le brevet ou n'ayant pas le
l'obtention du brevet vous avez
possibilité d'avoir accès à la formation
en apprentissage donc on a différents on
a différents niveaux on a une formation
qui est diplômante à la fin donc une
fois que vous l'obtenez on a différents
cursus qui peuvent aller de un an jusque
trois ans et ça peut aller jusqu'au bac
+ 5
il faut savoir que cette formation là
aussi à l'avantage justement d'avoir
donc une rémunération vous êtes
considéré donc en tant que salarié vu
que effectivement vous êtes au niveau
d'un contrat d'apprentissage donc en
alternance ça touche donc les publics
justement comme c'est bien écrit des
jeunes de 15 à 29 ans en ayant
possibilité pour ceux qui ont moins de
15 ans mais qui vont avoir 15 ans avant
donc le mois de décembre de l'année en
question ils peuvent effectuer aussi un
stage avec une convention de stage avec
l'établissement dans lequel ils sont
donc sur le moment même au niveau de
l'inscription au niveau des formations
il faut savoir qu'effectivement donc on
a le CFA qui permet justement d'avoir
cette alternance là qui va permettre aux
jeunes d'acquérir non seulement en
pratique mais également en théorie donc
tout ce cursus-là va vous permettre en
fait justement de continuer vos études
d'obtenir un diplôme d'acquérir en
expérience en pratique aussi et pourquoi
pas par la suite intégrer le
l'entreprise parce que parfois l'employ
décide de vous embaucher à la suite de
cette alternance là en ce qui concerne
du coup la rémunération effectivement
donc voilà il y a un tableau qui
concerne donc les différents on va dire
niveau de pourcentage du SMIC selon les
âges concernés donc là par exemple la
l'apprenti il a entre 16 ans et 17 ans
vous voyez que sur la première année il
a 27 % du SMIC sur la deuxième année du
contrat il va obtenir 39% du SMIC et sur
la troisième année du contrat on sera
aux alentours de 55% du SMIC donc bien
évidemment ceci évolue au fur et à
mesure de votre âge et donc c'est on a
le contrat de professionnalisation mais
qui pour le coup nous va pas forcément
nous toucher en tout cas au sein de la
Faculté des Métiers de l'Essonne on va
vraiment être en majorité sur le contrat
d'apprentissage donc voilà ce qui
concerne le tableau de Smic si jamais
vous vous avez un petit peu plus de
questions n'hésitez pas à les poser
alors je me permets de désinterrompre
parce que vous avez une question qui
vous est posée sur le chat un quiz pour
savoir un petit peu qu'elle à votre avis
quel est le nombre de d'apprentis qui
devient chef d'entreprise après leurs
études donc la question c'est à votre
avis 50% 10% 20%
je vous laisserai répondre
ok on est pas loin de 50% la réponse
c'est
30% 30% de chefs d'entreprise non alors
on me dit non je me trompe totalement
j'ai pas la réponse
attendez qu'est-ce qu'on me dit
c'est un compte pour cent de chef
d'entreprise d'apprenti deviennent chefs
j'ai été j'ai été perturbé
donc 50% un apprenti sur deux va devenir
chef d'entreprise artisanale et donc
voilà ça fait une perspective
intéressante de devenir son propre
employeur
ce qui est d'ailleurs effectivement
l'objectif de pas mal d'apprentis qu'on
a nous au sein de la Faculté des Métiers
donc que ce soit dans la filière
automobile ou autre notamment moi je le
vois dans la filière automobile parce
que je travaille donc en relation
directe avec eux et avec les entreprises
effectivement on a même chez nous des
candidats de l'apprentissage qui par la
suite non seulement ont été embauchés
chez le garagiste en question mais ils
sont aussi devenus associés de ce garage
donc effectivement ils deviennent
entrepreneurs par la suite alors tout on
n'a pas forcément un niveau précis en
termes d'études on peut devenir
garagiste avec un cap avec un bac pro
avec un BTS tout dépend de l'ampleur de
votre projet aussi personnel donc voilà
tout est tout est forcément accessible
et il y a aucun souci il y a pas mal de
jeunes qui ont déjà effectué
donc du coup là on va vous mettre une
petite vidéo qui va vous présenter donc
déjà l'ensemble de la Faculté des
Métiers et au sein du service de
l'automobile sur le site d'Évry bon
visionnage
[Musique]
bienvenue dans le plus grand centre de
formation d'alternance du sud-francilien
la Faculté des Métiers de l'Essonne
c'est 90 formations gratuites et
rémunérées du CAP au Bac + 5 dans 8
filières métiers réparties sur trois
sites
la Faculté des Métiers de l'Essonne
accompagne chaque année 3000 apprentis
et 5000 stagiaires de la formation
continue vers des parcours
professionnels réussis et de réelles
opportunités d'emplois en effet avec un
réseau de 2000 entreprises partenaires
elle affiche un taux d'insertion
professionnelle de plus de 80%
[Musique]
sur le site des vrais Courcouronnes la
filière service de l'automobile propose
des formations en carrosserie mécaniques
et peinture
d'anciens apprentis aujourd'hui salariés
ou chefs d'entreprise et des apprentis
actuellement en formation témoignent de
leur expérience ce qui est bien la
faculté des métiers c'est que entre
professeur et élèves il y a une bonne
ambiance tout le monde s'entend bien les
professeurs sont là pour nous et
vu que l'ambiance est bonne ça nous
donne envie de travailler et de réussir
et de continuer l'avantage de la Faculté
des Métiers c'est déjà la proximité avec
tout ce qui est le monde de l'automobile
on est vraiment sur le sujet au niveau
des ateliers on en a de l'accès au
niveau de tout ce qui est matériel on a
toutes les voitures à disposition sur le
parking de toute façon et au niveau des
équipements surtout dans les ateliers on
est quand même assez bien fourni on a de
quoi faire
on n'a pas à se plaindre de ce qu'on a
choisi l'apprentissage parce que il y
avait un revenu à la clé grâce à ça on a
une expérience professionnelle en plus
et à la fin on peut finir par être
embauché par l'entreprise qu'on a choisi
ce que j'apprécie moi personnellement
c'est le rapport qu'on a avec les
enseignants le plus pratiqué
régulièrement mon enseignant de pratique
qui lui était anciennement patron et du
coup bah en fait on peut vraiment
discuter avec lui et savoir ce que lui
plus faire et prendre de l'expérience
par rapport à lui son passé on a passé
si bonnes années quand même à la Faculté
des Métiers et on revient toujours bilan
positif moi je me sens extrêmement bien
que ce soit en entreprise ou au CFA donc
je regrette pas mon choix moi je
conseille le CFA des métiers de toute
façon parce que c'est un métier au bout
du chemin en fait tout simplement
si tu es à deux pas de la gare RER et
organisée autour d'espaces verts arborés
le campus d'Évry de la Faculté des
Métiers de l'Essonne propose des
équipements dédiés modernes et
performants deux amphithéâtres
un restaurant d'applications
un centre de ressources
et un complexe sportif
deux espaces de restauration sont à
votre disposition self et cafétéria
enfin la Faculté des Métiers de
l'Essonne dispose d'un service d'accès à
l'alternance proposant notamment une
prépa apprentissage et permettant à la
faculté des métiers des scènes d'être
fiers d'intégrer tout type de handicap
alors n'hésitez pas rejoignez-nous
donc du coup j'espère que vous avez eu
un bon visionnage au niveau de la
présentation de la filière automobile au
sein du site d'Evry de la Faculté des
Métiers donc en ce qui concerne
justement les sites de la Faculté des
Métiers de l'Essonne on est sur trois
sites donc bandoufles qui va concerner
plus tout ce qui va être industrie donc
conception fabrication et maintenant sur
Évry donc le site qui vous a été
présenté il y aura tout ce qui va être
donc automobile l'assistanagestion la
coiffure esthétique le commerce une
partie énergétique électrotech et tout
ce qui va être donc commerce hôtellerie
tourisme et le métier du goût et sur bah
si donc là on va vraiment être tout ce
qui va être comptabilité gestion le
commerce donc de proximité et tout ce
qui va être immobilier pardon et
informatique donc vous avez le détail un
petit peu donc on est autour de presque
donc ensuite au niveau de la filière
automobile on va être séparé sur donc
deux types de formation on aura la
formation mécanique qui va se nommer
maintenance des véhicules option
véhicules particuliers donc ça va être
sur des véhicules légers du quotidien
qui va concerner un petit peu donc tout
type de public et sur la partie
carrosserie donc il y aura la partie
carrosserie et la partie peinture
donc là voilà on vous montre un petit
peu dans quel sens vous voyez vous allez
pouvoir évoluer au sein de la Faculté
des Métiers via la filière automobile
donc si jamais voilà vous êtes issu de
3e à partir de la troisième vous pouvez
intégrer soit un CAP Réparation des
carrosseries qui va s'effectuer sur deux
ans soit donc un bac pro professionnel
Réparation des carrosseries qui celui va
s'effectuer sur trois ans donc ils vont
l'intégrer directement à partir de la
seconde et sur la partie donc maintenant
des véhicules il y aura un cap qui sera
donc sur deux ans et un bac pro donc
maintenant c'est des véhicules qui
celui-ci va pouvoir être intégré aussi
sur trois ans ou deux ans alors je me
permets de t'interrompre parce que on a
trois apprentis autour de la table c'est
le moment de leur demander ce qu'ils ont
fait avant d'intégrer
cette formation par la voie de
l'apprentissage Nathan qu'est-ce que tu
as fait quel est ton cursus avant
d'intégrer ta formation là actuelle
alors moi j'ai toujours été en général
j'ai jamais fait de d'études à côté ou
voilà j'ai une fois que j'ai passé ma
troisième je me suis dirigé vers une
voie professionnelle et j'aimerais tout
de suite plus parce que c'est pas
forcément fait pour moi et d'accord
seconde pro Première Pro et bac pro ok
merci Nathan soit Nolan
avant d'intégrer ta formation actuelle
pas forcément beaucoup de moyenne j'ai
loupé mon brevet etc du coup bah j'ai
décidé de repasser mon brevet
des meilleurs notes et je savais pas ce
que je voulais faire donc j'ai fait un
stage de troisième en carrosserie et ça
va tout de suite plus donc bah après je
suis parti là dedans d'accord bac pro ça
a été une révélation de faire en fait
ton stage de 3e
et ça c'est important de le dire parce
que ça permet de mettre un pied
dans l'entreprise et donc je pense qu'il
faut essayer de bien choisir
l'entreprise dans laquelle on va aller
et pas de le faire par défaut
comme ça c'est ça c'est important parce
que toi du coup ça t'a révélé une envie
de faire cette profession et donc c'est
pas un choix anodin que de faire son
stage en troisième
mon cher Théodore quel a été ton
parcours avant d'intégrer ton actuel
formation et bien après la troisième ne
sachant pas quoi faire je suis allé à
une formation à côté de chez moi cela ne
m'a pas plu et j'ai très vite changé
pour bien m'inscrire à la DME et faire
ce qui me plaisait
métallier d'accord ce qui travaille sur
les objets de cuisine portail etc dans
le bâtiment c'est pourtant un beau
métier mais ça a pas été ton choix ça
t'a pas plu et donc tu as pu changer de
voix te réorienter tu étais en seconde à
l'époque où tu l'as fait d'accord et tu
as réintégré une seconde d'accord tu as
réintégré la seconde du bac pro
automobile
sans complicité ok merci les jeunes
donc on va passer au
quiz il vous a été posé la question
sur le chat l'apprentissage est-il
réservé aux élèves qui ne peuvent pas
continuer des études en enseignement
général ou qui ne sont pas motivés pour
continuer ses études là vous avez
répondu pour 66% faux et pour 33% vrai
et bien vous avez raison c'est faux
c'est pas parce qu'on est mauvaise élève
qu'on va dans l'apprentissage il y a de
très bons élèves qui choisissent
de tout de suite apprendre un métier et
donc c'est c'est pas le cas c'est pas
vrai c'est pas parce que vous êtes en
apprentissage que vous êtes des mauvais
élèves et en général justement en
apprentissage même si on peut dire que
le niveau des matières générales sont un
petit peu en dessous que la voie
générale et bien les élèves ont de très
bonnes notes s'avèrent de très bons
élèves quand il s'agit d'apprendre un
métier
on va continuer cette présentation
alors
je vais vous présenter Cécile qui va
prendre ma place Cécile travaille à la
chambre de métier de l'artisanat elle
est médiatrice de l'apprentissage son
rôle c'est de faire le lien entre
l'employeur le maître d'apprentissage
qui forme le jeûne et le jeune apprenti
et donc elle va nous livrer trois
conseils pour bien réussir sa formation
en apprentissage alors bonjour à tous
voilà donc effectivement en tant que
comme Sandrine vient de le dire et de me
présenter je suis médiatrice donc
j'interviens quand il y a des soucis et
Dieu merci la plupart du temps tout se
passe très bien d'ailleurs je ne vous
connais pas donc c'est que tout va bien
voilà mais on va dire que c'est trois
petits conseils sous forme de tuto on
essaye de s'adapter à vous pour que ça
vous parle un maximum
sur des flexions des problématiques qui
reviennent d'où de par mon activité donc
le premier point c'est montrer sa
motivation alors ça ça englobe beaucoup
de choses montrer sa motivation
qu'est-ce que c'est c'est tout
simplement bah du coup être à l'heure
montrer qu'on a envie de faire autre
chose faire autre chose quand on a fini
une tâche ne pas hésiter effectivement à
redemander
à pas tourner en rond voilà ben je sais
que c'est pas simple parce que vous êtes
très jeune et que il faut effectivement
aller contre cette timidité c'est pas
toujours simple aller voir son maître
d'apprentissage et se dire bon bah là du
coup qu'est-ce que je fais maintenant
mais ça pourra jamais
vous êtes reproché de demander ce genre
de choses être à l'heure ben oui tout
simplement parce qu'effectivement c'est
important vous faites maintenant partie
d'une équipe de travail et comme comme
la souligner très justement
[Musique]
presque du premier coup je vais
effectivement vous êtes salarié donc
tout chaque minute compte vous êtes payé
souvent ça fait la différence mais c'est
vrai qu'il faut il faut il faut souvent
vous le rappeler mais c'est très
important le deuxième point c'est se
passer de son téléphone portable alors
ça je pense que c'est un truc qui est
vraiment récurrent et qui revient
franchement
honnêtement dans presque 100% des cas
que je peux avoir tout simplement on
comprend vous êtes né avec donc c'est
quelque chose de tellement naturel chez
vous donc on le conçoit c'est tout à
fait tout à fait normal mais il va
falloir en entreprise et comme à l'école
d'ailleurs mais en entreprise encore
plus parce que vous allez apprendre à un
métier donc il faut vraiment que vous
vous concentrez vous concentrer
de vraiment de A à Z vous aurez
effectivement des pauses comme à l'école
où vous pourrez reprendre votre
téléphone sans aucun problème
dans les dans les entreprises les
apprentis qui sont qui sont dans
l'artisanat en plus ça peut être
dangereux enfin je veux dire il y a de
l'hygiène enfin ça dépend des métiers
effectivement je sors du de du goût donc
effectivement là on est dans l'hygiène
là dans l'automobile c'est carrément
dangereux ça peut être carrément
dangereux donc voilà on fait attention à
ça et surtout ça fait pas sérieux donc
les Tik Tok et les snapchat
voilà même si c'est très tentant il faut
il faut éviter parce qu'en plus ça
empêche la concentration
encore je vous le reçois ligne vous
apprenez à un travail et c'est pas
simple donc
voilà surtout vraiment fait un gros
effort là dessus vous allez avoir des
pauses vous allez pouvoir récupérer
votre portable vous aurez plein de
motifs plein de messages et ça va vous
faire plaisir pour la satisfaite la
satisfaction personnelle vous verrez ça
sera ça sera bien
ça vous fera plaisir quand vous pourrez
le récupérer mais vraiment fait un gros
effort là dessus
et le troisième point c'est solliciter
des échanges avec le maître
d'apprentissage
alors qu'est-ce que ça veut dire en fait
c'est on en revient un peu à la au
premier point c'est surtout essayer
d'instaurer en fait un
rapport de confiance et un rapport de
discussion avec votre maître
d'apprentissage je sais que sur le
concret c'est pas toujours facile parce
que ils sont toujours occupés ou voilà
et que vous vous allez pas forcément
oser mais ce que je conseille souvent
c'est effectivement
d'essayer de faire par exemple si vous
avez une semaine de cours et une semaine
d'entreprise à la fin de la semaine
d'entreprise entre le jeudi et le
vendredi par exemple d'essayer de faire
un point même si c'est 5 minutes il y a
pas besoin de faire que ça prenne un
important infini c'est juste essayer de
faire un point sur ce qui a pas été ce
qui a été sur quoi je dois faire des
efforts et c'est tout en fait c'est
juste faire un point justement bah s'il
y a quelque chose qui va pas on se le
dit tout de suite et ça ne prend pas
après des des proportions après qui sont
compliquées et après on rentre dans des
conflits qui sont enfin qui n'ont pas
lieu d'être et souvent la cause et le
manque le manque de de communication
tout simplement c'est vraiment 90% des
des conflits que je peux avoir voilà
donc vraiment ces trois points là
je pense que ces trois points clés qui
peut bien enclencher qui peuvent bien en
enclencher à faire votre affaire votre
apprentissage merci Cécile pour ces
trois super conseils
mais je pense que si vous choisissez
cette voix
les professeurs m'ont pas de vous
sensibiliser sur ces questions-là et qui
sont quand même hyper importantes donc
voilà on va continuer cette petite
présentation il y en a donc du coup là
on va arriver sur la procédure
d'inscription au sein de la filière
automobile chez la Faculté des Métiers
de l'Essonne donc il faut savoir que on
a possibilité de s'inscrire via le site
internet donc de la FDME
comment vous allez procéder donc voilà
c'est très simple c'est c'est écrit non
sur blanc mais voilà il faut aller donc
sur ce prix inscrire vous allez choisir
effectivement donc la filière qui vous
intéresse et une fois que vous
choisissez la filière qui vous intéresse
vous allez remplir toutes les
informations nécessaires à partir de ce
moment-là nous entre temps on va
recevoir donc votre inscription il faut
savoir que pour valider l'inscription il
faut avoir une entreprise donc moi qui
suis chargé de développement commercial
et qui est relationnel entreprise il
faut savoir que je peux effectivement
intervenir pour vous aider à trouver une
entreprise mais pas dans les médias donc
l'objectif c'est que vous puissiez déjà
effectuer quelques petites recherches en
amont on effectuera aussi un entretien
donc à la suite de ce dossier
d'inscription pour avoir vos motivations
pardon voir un petit peu si voilà est-ce
que vous êtes intéressé par le métier
est-ce que c'est juste l'obtention d'un
diplôme est-ce que vous êtes sûr de
vouloir intégrer ce métier là parce
qu'il y a quand même des conditions de
travail faut savoir que quand on
travaille dans un garage en hiver il
peut faire très froid on n'est pas dans
des bureaux isolés ou ce genre de choses
en été il peut faire très chaud aussi
donc voilà il faut vraiment se
renseigner un petit peu plus
pour avoir toutes les informations
nécessaires à l'inscription j'ai une
question vous vous savez comme comme
nous tous que on parle beaucoup le
métier en tension en ce moment notamment
dans le secteur du bâtiment de la
restauration est-ce que c'est le cas
dans le secteur de l'automobile alors
dans le secteur de l'automobile moi qui
suis du coup en lien avec les
entreprises ils sont beaucoup beaucoup à
la recherche d'apprentis voilà alors
pourquoi je pourquoi ils sont en
recherche d'apprentis alors
effectivement vous ça vous permet de
faire une inscription d'avoir un diplôme
etc mais il faut savoir aussi que du
côté de l'État ils apportent une aide
donc au contrat d'apprentissage à
l'entreprise alors avant il y avait des
aides qui
différé en fonction de l'âge et du
niveau d'études etc aujourd'hui depuis
janvier 2023 on a une aide qui est
globale à tout type donc de secteurs ou
tout type d'âge ou de formation qui est
à hauteur de 6000 euros l'entreprise
touche 6000 euros d'aide pour pouvoir
accueillir des apprentis et leur
permettre d'être salarié de l'automobile
plus tard et donc c'est des métiers
enfin c'est des filières où il y a de
l'emploi où il y a des postes à prendre
puisque c'est un métier qui est un petit
peu en tension c'est pas l'équivalent de
la restauration bien sûr mais il y a
beaucoup de demandes de la part des
garages des carrossiers ou même ça peut
être aussi dans des usines par exemple
le cas de j'avais vu un client du
cuillère pour pour la petite anecdote et
il me faisait part que les magasinsiers
de pièces détachées se font de plus en
plus rares on a des personnes qui
partent à la retraite et on a de moins
en moins on va dire entre parenthèses
des jeunes qui sont dans ce secteur ou
dans ce métier-là donc effectivement
c'est un peu sous tension via les
départs de retraite mais par contre
c'est un secteur qui est ouvert à
l'apprentissage qui est ouvert au
nouveau salarié et ils sont vraiment à
l'écoute du marché pour intégrer des
apprentis donc il y a du boulot dans ce
secteur et une question que je voulais
vous poser c'est on a parlé des aides
qui sont destinées à l'employeur est-ce
que les futurs apprentis
et ce métier là parce que s'il s'agit
pas seulement de l'avoir mais ce métier
là faut se renseigner sur vos éventuels
aides possibles je voulais poser une
question tout à l'heure on a parlé du
salaire je voulais poser la question à
nos jeunes qui sont là si c'est pas trop
indiscret d'y répondre Nathan tu as quel
âge alors moi j'ai 15 ans tu as 15 ans
et je peux savoir combien tu es rétribué
par l'entreprise pour travailler en
apprentissage par mois
450 euros par mois 450 euros à 15 ans
tout en apprenant un métier que qui te
plaît on est d'accord c'est pas forcé
merci Nathan 450 euros soit
loan
quel âge as-tu Louane tu as 16 ans
combien es-tu rémunéré
550 euros
tu as des avantages il y a la moitié du
Navigo qui est payé par l'entreprise
également
donc vous avez quasiment le même statut
qu'un salarié lambda en étant en
apprentissage et protégé quand même par
alors justement on en revient à ce que
disait du coup Cécile ils ont
effectivement les tickets du salarié
voilà considéré comme en tant que tel
d'où on parlait des absences et des
retards non justifiés qui vont
effectivement impacter cette ce salaire
là parce qu'ils sont considérés en tant
que salarié oui ils touchent un salaire
mais en plus l'entreprise paye tout ou
partie de la formation donc ça
représente pour l'entreprise un coût un
investissement et c'est pour ça que les
entreprises recherchent des apprentis
pour leur permettre de former leur futur
salariés ils investissent dans votre
formation dans la formation en
apprentissage du jeûne et donc dans le
but plus tard de l'accueillir en tant
que salarié si ça on fait la faire
toi Théodore quel âge as-tu
je peux te demander quel est ton salaire
par mois en apprentissage 458 458 net
comme comme Nathan à peu près voilà donc
c'est quand même pas mal 15-16 ans entre
400 et
550 euros et 550 euros et ben ça permet
de faire des trucs plutôt sympa et de
prévoir pour l'avenir c'est ça
voilà alors on en est là donc voilà et
sinon en ce qui concerne si vous avez
plus de questions si vous souhaitez
venir visiter les ateliers si voilà vous
voulez faire une journée portes ouvertes
donc il y en a une qui a eu lieu le 28
janvier donc samedi dernier ça s'est
très bien passé vous pouvez venir
accompagner de vos parents vous pouvez
venir accompagner de vos amis on fait
vraiment en sorte de tout vous expliquer
en détail sur les différents niveaux que
ce soit cap bac pro on essaie aussi de
s'intéresser donc à leurs projets
personnel pour savoir si par exemple il
est plus intéressant pour eux d'intégrer
directement une première en bas de pro
et faire le bac pro en deux ans ou de
reprendre en seconde parce qu'ils n'ont
pas de connaissances sur l'aspect
mécanique et carrosserie donc voilà les
différentes portes ouvertes on est sur
les différents sites nous en partie la
filière automobile on sera sur le site
d'Évry Courcouronnes donc ni bandoufle
ni Massy et vous avez les dates des
prochaines portes ouvertes qui vont
avoir lieu pour pouvoir vous renseigner
donc la prochaine 18 mars c'est ça c'est
le moment où il faut s'occuper de son
orientation quand on est en troisième
vraiment c'est pas on n'est pas en
avance à 18 mars faut vraiment s'en
occuper c'est ça 18 14 avril bah ouais
enfin voilà c'est le moment alors oui
oui c'est le moment il faut savoir aussi
que c'est important de préciser que on
fonctionne vraiment pas en ordre
d'ancienneté c'est important de le
préciser nous l'objectif c'est qu'un
candidat peut valider ça son inscription
une fois qu'il a une entreprise voilà
donc il faut on est vraiment sur du
premier arrivé premier servi quoi les
classes sont principalement donc
comptabiliser sur 15 places 14 15 places
donc les plats sont assez chers comme on
dit donc voilà essayer vraiment de vous
y prendre à l'avance faire votre
pré-inscription vous recevez un mail
automatique pour fournir tous les
documents type CV bulletin de notes etc
et vous avez une fiche de renseignement
qui vous est envoyé pour que dès qu'il
trouve un employeur il ne la remplissent
il nous la renvoie ça va de
l'inscription mais tous les jeunes ils
sont accompagnés dans leur inscription
oui alors par les parents et puis que je
reviens à ce que je disais tout à
l'heure une fois que je fais un
entretien avec eux donc je leur laisse
quand même un petit délai de trois
quatre semaines pour chercher eux-mêmes
on refait un point par la suite pour
téléphonique j'ai pas oublié de se
déplacer et après moi je peux les aider
à rencontrer les entreprises oui et puis
c'est le moment de faire jouer ces
relations ses copains pour d'en parler
voilà je cherche une entreprise je veux
tel type de de garage est-ce que vous
pouvez m'aider c'est tout le monde à
tout le monde c'est c'est une affaire de
réseau c'est comme quand on cherche un
job et ben on en parle et puis ils
peuvent ils peuvent en parler vous
pouvez faire part de votre expérience au
niveau de votre recherche est-ce que
vous avez du mal à trouver une
entreprise alors comment vous avez
procédé les garçons
moi au début je sais que c'était un peu
compliqué
mais après j'en ai parlé à mon entourage
et moi c'est grâce à mon père donc voilà
je suis rentré
et bien dans l'entreprise
de salariés je sais pas trop parce que
il y a aussi la mécanique il y a des
gens dans les bureaux
c'est un garage
concessionnels Carrefour tout ça OK et
donc toi ça c'est le bouche à oreille
c'est le fait d'en avoir parlé son papa
t'a aidé à trouver c'est souvent le cas
toi Théodore comment as-tu trouvé ton
entreprise j'essayais les entreprises de
la région
oreille et c'est surtout grâce aux
entreprises qui m'ont redirigé vers
d'autres entreprises auxquelles on
n'avait pas accès sur Internet ou
vraiment même si
l'employeur dit non des fois il donne un
petit coup de pouce et il nous laisse
pas repartir les mains vides donc c'est
toujours intéressant de venir voir
l'employeur en personne ça fait un
argument en plus avec un CV encore
carrément tu t'es rendu dans le garage
ou la conception avec ton CV ça fait du
porte-à-porte quoi
[Musique]
et toi Nathan comment comment tu as
procédé moi j'ai fait des CV des lettres
de motivation et mon père m'a emmené à
toutes les entreprises j'y suis allé et
voilà j'ai fait assez vite j'ai eu
beaucoup de chance parce que j'avais
fait 12 lettres de motivation et 12 CV
et j'ai la première entreprise que j'ai
été elle m'a pris mais vraiment beaucoup
de chance et j'en suis content
[Musique]
d'amener vos parents parce que faut
quand même être enfin vous allez être
tout seul dans l'entreprise donc il y
aura pas vos parents avec vous il faut
voilà
ils peuvent vous accompagner jusqu'à la
porte du garage et puis une fois que
vous êtes face à l'entreprise ou
l'employeur et ben vous y allez et en
fait il faut pas avoir peur quoi ils
vont pas vous mangez
vous êtes des grands garçons grandes
filles alors ce que je voulais dire
c'est que les métiers de l'automobile ça
ne concerne pas que les garçons ah non
on est d'accord ah bah dans la village
carrosserie on a déjà je crois on a deux
filles
voilà il y en a deux et au sein de la
filière mécanique également voilà et
c'est une filière qui intéresse de plus
en plus les filles c'est en train de
changer on est en train de casser ses
codes métiers de garçon métier de fille
alors il y a plus de métiers pour les
filles ou les garçons bon c'est pas
parce qu'elles ont pas les gros bises
photos qu'elles peuvent pas lever je
vous assure que des fois c'est les plus
assidu donc voilà donc on est d'accord
je voulais j'avais une question à poser
ah oui Nathan
bon tu l'as
oui mais quelqu'un
tu sais est-ce que tu sais déjà
quel métier tu vas exercer et pourquoi
tu as choisi l'automobile quoi pour
faire quel job bah moi je me suis je
suis allé dans l'automobile parce que
déjà j'aime beaucoup tout ce qui touche
aux voitures etc et j'aime beaucoup les
voitures d'exception de collection etc
et comme ça m'intéressait beaucoup de de
refaçonner un véhicule bah j'ai été dans
la carrosserie j'ai hésité avec la
mécanique mais pendant mon stage de
troisième j'ai c'était la carrosserie
qui m'a le plus intéressante et donc tu
as un projet d'entreprise là tu as un
projet futur après tes études je
voudrais je voudrais ouvrir déjà mon
garage et avoir un camion un gros camion
avec tous les outils nécessaires et me
déplacer et me déplacer c'est la
clientèle donc c'est en fait une
carrosserie mobile quoi c'est génial
c'est le feu le Food truck enfin c'est
pas le Food mais parce que
de demain quoi enfin c'est qu'invente là
espèce de nouveau mode d'exercice de ce
métier voilà et donc du coup après ton
bac tu rentres en tant que salarié et
après tu vas travailler ce projet quoi
c'est simple moi je vais je vais je vais
terminer mon bac mais après je vais
faire un CAP en peinture d'accord pour
être carrossier peintre et bah je
pourrais faire vraiment un plus grand
panel de
plus dessus et bien que tu en parles
parce que du coup c'est important de le
souligner sur l'aspect carrosserie il
faut savoir que si vous entamez un bac
pro carrosserie vous allez
automatiquement passer votre cap parce
que il y a des jeunes qui n'obtiennent
pas forcément le bac mais au moins ils
ressortent avec un diplôme CAP qui passe
sur la première année ça veut dire que
en seconde il passe le diplôme pour
passer en première et en première il
passe quand même un cap comme ça si en
terminale le candidat ou la candidate ne
tient pas son bac et il repartent avec
un diplôme CAP lequel ils peuvent quand
même intégrer le monde du travail très
bien merci cette précision
Louane
quel est ton projet futur après tes
études est-ce que tu es une idée de ce
que tu vas faire ouais t'es une idée on
a de la chance
[Musique]
entre sur avion etc
il y a beaucoup de choses
mon formateur il me l'a expliqué donc
moi au début je j'aurais bien aimé faire
avion tout ça mais après j'ai un petit
peu changé là j'hésite entre deux choses
c'est soit de faire de la restauration
automobile sur des véhicules d'exception
un peu comme Nathan donc des jaguars des
véhicules anciens ou sinon expert
automobile sinon expert automobile donc
toi tu as déjà tes choix qui sont
définis après tes études toi Théodore
qu'est-ce que tu vas faire après ton bac
comme mes camarades je vais poursuivre
par un CAP en peinture après un CAP en
mécanique et
rejoindre une entreprise et voir comment
ça se passe
avec des projets personnels qui
développeront les années d'accord très
bien merci
n'oublie pas de réfléchir à des
questions on est là pour
pour répondre à toutes vos
interrogations à lever vos freins
voilà n'hésitez surtout pas à réfléchir
à vos questions on va bientôt passer à
la phase de question-Réponses donc vous
trouverez sur ce slide là à la à l'écran
tous les contacts nécessaires
pour avoir des renseignements pour
s'inscrire pour participer aux journées
portes ouvertes donc voilà je vous
invite à faire une capture d'écran où je
sais pas ou de toute façon tous ces
slides seront disponibles sur le site de
la Chambre de métier d'artisanat de
l'Essonne vous retrouverez les
enregistrements de de ces web
conférences donc bon c'est pas grave ça
va pas fait de capture d'écran vous
retrouverez tous les éléments sur le
site de la Chambre de métier les mêmes
sur le site de la faculté
également et sur le site de la
de la Faculté des Métiers de l'Essonne
on avance
j'ai perdu alors on en est où là
donc voilà
je vais relever on va relever les
questions sur le chat
j'en ai une première à alors je sais pas
qui peut répondre à ça si c'est toi
derrière ma ou ou les jeunes on nous
demande quel est le salaire moyen d'un
mécanicien
donc alors le salaire moyen brut on va
dire brut ou net ça dépend
ça doit être
2000 mais
2000 brutes en début de carrière oui en
début de carrière
sur pas mal de véhicules et puis il faut
savoir qu'aussi des fois les garages
travaillent le samedi alors donc il faut
prendre en compte que c'est sur six
jours et pas cinq jours et il y a
possibilité aussi des fois de faire
plusieurs interventions de ce cours
autre donc c'est un métier effectivement
où on peut bien gagner sa vie mais c'est
un métier où il y a des conditions qu'il
faut prendre en compte oui comme dans
beaucoup de métiers les métiers de les
infirmiers c'est tout pareil il gagne au
départ pas beaucoup plus je pense alors
qu'ils ont fait trois années d'études
supérieures et avec des contraintes les
weekends des nuits des gardes et autres
donc dans beaucoup de métiers il y a des
contraintes faut pas se leurrer dans
l'automobile aussi c'est ça voilà donc
le salaire moyen d'un mécanicien on a
dit au départ au démarrage une fois que
vous êtes employé c'est autour de 2000
brutes ce qui fait 1500 1600 1600
sans avoir fait d'heures sups sans prise
exactement de base
oui bien sûr
c'est comme tout pour être faut se la
donner
par exemple Ferrari ou pas ils vont
chercher l'exception vraiment le
mécanicien qui donne tout qui travaille
propre et bien alpine aussi
toutes les grandes marques comme ça et
ils cherchent vraiment le carrossier ou
le mécanisme qui travaille bien et qui
bosse dur quoi alors il recherche
vraiment uniquement des des personnes
qui sont motivées c'est vraiment le
critère qui revient le plus quand je
fais des visites d'entreprise ou quand
je vais en prospecter des nouvelles ils
recherchent vraiment des apprentis qui
alors une demande même pas le niveau
d'études ou l'âge non la motivation
motiver qui soit prêt à s'investir pour
pourquoi pas par la suite l'embaucher
voilà
rechercher pour avoir du quelqu'un qui
qui travaille dans le garage c'est ça
c'est le principe de l'apprentissage
c'est c'est d'intégrer ensuite alors
l'entreprise dans laquelle on a été
formé ou une autre bien sûr bien d'avoir
c'est une première expérience tout en
apprenant et ça dans un CV et ben c'est
des
qu'est-ce que au fond ça change dans
l'apprentissage
est-ce que ça complexifie le métier ou
pas
alors côté carrosserie peinture je pense
pas que ça vous intéresse
la peinture et bien comme on utilise
beaucoup de machines à contacter
électrique et bien comme le moteur sera
entièrement électrique on doit avoir une
formation pour avoir une adaptation de
connaissances pour pouvoir désactiver ce
moteur en utilisant ces machines assez
spécifiques sinon ça fait boom
garage
je vais la retenir celle-là
et côté mécanique par contre oui côté
mécanique alors pour pour la petite info
ce qui a été super sympathique et qui a
été fait à la filière automobile côté
maintenance des véhicules donc on a le
côté carrosserie peinture et le côté
maintenance des véhicules qui ont
travaillé ensemble sur un projet commun
donc ils ont ramené une ancienne voiture
de collection Renault qui datait un
petit peu des années 90 ils ont refait
du coup l'intérieur pour la rendre
électrique donc ils ont branché des
batteries dans le coffre ils ont
vraiment refait donc tout l'intérieur et
l'aspect carrosserie peinture s'est
occupé de l'extérieur donc ils ont
refait vraiment ils ont tout customisé
ils ont tout refait aux couleurs qui les
intéressaient et c'est un projet que
vous pouvez venir du coup regarder parce
qu'on a collé différentes photos qui
montrent les différentes étapes si un
jour vous venez aux journées portes
ouvertes et que vous faites la visite
d'ateliers on vous montrera
effectivement ce projet OK
j'aimerais que derrière l'écran là
est-ce que est-ce que les professeurs
qui accompagnent les élèves là peuvent
peut-être sont des la classe pour savoir
si un certain nombre de de jeunes
seraient intéressés par par ce métier
parce qu'il y en a plein des métiers
dans l'automobile et nous faire part sur
le chat du nombre à peu près de
personnes qui seraient éventuellement
intéressées le temps le temps de faire
ça je vais poser des questions à aux
apprentis pour savoir
quelles sont les compétences et les
appétences
qui sont nécessaires pour faire ce
métier parce que dans tout métier bah on
a plus ou moins selon notre personnalité
notre éducation ou autre bah une
compétence une appétence pour telle ou
tel domaine donc qu'est-ce qu'il faut
avoir comme
qualité pour faire ce métier
Nathan tout d'abord il faut de la
motivation parce que si on n'est pas
motivé on va on va pas vouloir terminer
avant l'heure ou voilà et on va pas y
arriver et il faut de la rigueur parce
qu'il faut voilà faut pas se dire bon
bah j'arrive pas je vais aller sur une
autre voiture ou à la fois essayer de la
terminer et si on y arrive pas faut
toujours te dire que qu'on est en mettre
d'apprentissage qui est là pour nous
aider aussi d'accord mais est-ce qu'il
faut j'imagine qu'il faut être précis
quand même parce que moi je la mécanique
tout ça c'est vraiment pas mon mon truc
comme pas mal de femmes mais bon mais
j'imagine qu'il faut des qualités en
particulier pour faire de la mécanique
bah après la mécanique c'est pas c'est
pas vraiment mon domaine mais oui il en
faut alors la carrosserie pardon
la carrosserie où il faut quand même pas
mal de précisions quoi quand il s'agit
de bah mettre du du mastic sur par
exemple une aile ou une porte faut
vraiment redessiner la forme parfaite
toujours pas que à la peinture ça se
voit ou ouais donc il faut avoir un
petit sens de l'esthétisme aussi
perfectionnisme aussi perfectionniste
qu'est-ce que vous avez
faut être manuel faut être habile de ses
mains ouais
pour toi Théodore tu ajouterais quelque
chose
tout savoir sur sortir de situation
gênante comme
son confort il faut savoir se mettre
dans son confort pour
pour bien travailler dans une position
instable ou vraiment ce ménager un
maximum parce que des fois on peut on
peut
se blesser
parce que des fois il y a des portes qui
sont soulevées le coin des portes peut
être pointu donc c'est respecté les
gestes techniques qui sont appris pour
pouvoir se voilà se protéger c'est un
peu comme dans le bâtiment il y a des
gestes qui sont qui font en sorte que on
fait attention à son corps en faisant un
beau geste
faut bien s'équiper il faut voilà
respecter les gestes qui très dangereux
il y a des disqueuses
de pays d'accord oui tout ça c'est
normal on rentre dans un métier qui qui
a des contraintes de sécurité OK
alors il y a quatre élèves on me dit
alors il nous reste 5 minutes il y a 4
élèves sur 30 qui seraient intéressés
dont deux filles je dis chapeau bon deux
filles qui se rêvent intéressés par les
métiers de l'automobile donc je vous
invite à pas louper les portes ouvertes
à vous renseigner et à poser des
questions à ceux qui connaissent bien le
métier à aller à la faculté des métiers
pour rencontrer des jeunes faut surtout
pas hésiter ils peuvent passer nous
rendre visite même si il y a pas des
journées portes ouvertes d'accord il y a
possibilité de venir au bureau nous en
fait on est au bureau sont vraiment dans
le bâtiment de la filière automobile
d'accord donc il y a aucun problème dans
une autre classe il y a il y a trois
élèves sur 16 qui sont aussi intéressés
par par les métiers de l'automobile donc
bon et en plus il évolue beaucoup le
métier de l'automobile et puis il y a
je sais pas si on peut appeler ça comme
ça une classe
de de
la carrosserie qui s'appelle le tuning
moi je suis pas très forte là dedans et
justement il y a une question qui a été
posée sur le fait qu'il existe ce que
vous savez s'il existe des des garages
spécialisés dans le tuning alors au
moins on est seul est-ce que vous savez
si ça existe les garçons vous pouvez
nous nous en faire part nous en citer
quelques-uns je sais que moi j'avais
fait bah là où j'avais fait mon stage où
j'ai décidé que j'allais faire de la
carrosserie c'était une c'était une
enfin un garage mécanique et carrosserie
qui faisait beaucoup de tuning de
préparation moteur etc et donc c'était à
Égly Égly c'est garage des verrasing qui
est spécialisé en Honda mais qui fait
aussi beaucoup d'autres voitures ils
font des ça peut être des Aston Martin
il y avait eu un
Classe G préparé Brabus il y avait eu
beaucoup de choses et franchement oui
qui font du très bon travail et c'est
possible il y en a beaucoup il y a
beaucoup il y en a qui sont spécialisés
dans le tuning il y en a qui sont
spécialisés dans des marques de voitures
aussi nous on a un garage qui est
spécialisé sur les voitures Porsche
le plaisir là j'en connais un autre
garage
[Musique]
ça rappelle plus
non je pense que mais il doit y en avoir
oui il suffit de se renseigner
plus précisément auprès de la faculté
des métiers ou sur le net voilà
celui d'église est très bien on nous dit
donc n'hésitez pas alors
je pense qu'on a fait le tour de toutes
les questions
sur ce sujet là à moins que vous ayez
une dernière autre question
je vais attendre quelques minutes
secondes
je pense qu'on a fait tout le tour en
tout cas
sachez que
la web conférence elle sera en ligne que
vous avez des rendez-vous à la faculté
des métiers pour les journées portes
ouvertes et puis rien ne vous empêche
d'aller taper à la porte d'un garage
pour poser d'autres questions ou
rencontrer des apprentis il y a plein de
solutions pour avoir de l'information je
vous remercie d'avoir été aussi nombreux
à participer à cette deuxième one
conférence de la journée
je vous invite à rejoindre nos autres
conférences là dans deux minutes
pardon dans deux minutes ou cet
après-midi sur d'autres sujets le
bâtiment la beauté ou la fleuristerie je
vous souhaite une très belle journée à
vous et merci encore d'avoir participé à
cette webconférence à bientôt